i was invited to the white house for
this influencer event
who was president president
obama black friend
he wasn't he was supposed to be there
and he wasn't there i was upset he was
late and i was like okay
[Laughter]
okay
okay go jake go
do you go there
okay you gotta do it joe biden
no he of course he was there did he know
he was there
or was he looking for cotton candy
man but i i was just like hey
all these influencers are going here
there's 30 of them they're all going to
be making a vlog and i thought to myself
how could i make my vlog better than
theirs
i'm gonna sleep in the white house fire
where did you hide out so i snuck away
into a bathroom
and just stood in there until like
four or five a.m
and nobody noticed nothing not a not a
not a peep they didn't they didn't even
know i was crazy without the [ __ ] this
is crazy every other country is [ __ ]
every other country wants to take out
our presidents or [ __ ] bro hold on i
walk out the front door and post the
video and that's when they found out get
did they ask you to take it down yeah
immediately right yeah and they showed
up at my front door oh [ __ ] like the
actual secret service showed up and then
my brother like got the people to come
back so that's why i thought it was real
ah
so wait what was the convo with secret
service when they showed up they were
like
really funny they were trying to
intimidate
we subscribed love the content
they just came here to say what's up bro
yeah yeah
wait why i don't get it
i was like him being like yo get in a
check
yeah um
yeah they just tried to intimidate me
and be like take the video down or else
and this
this is a terrible representation we're
disgraced that you did this and you're
never going to be able to come back to
the white house you need to take the
video down right now i was like i have
permission to be there i have permission
to film i'm sorry i'm not taking the
video down and greg paul
was there and he goes you should be
thanking him he found the flaw in your
[ __ ] system oh hell is that fire
[ __ ] gun
and uh
even though do you think you could beat
up his death
he was a piece of [ __ ] for leaving them
outside
these are country boys their babysitter
was just
outside nature though the best
babysitter
that is how did i not hear about this
vlog that's crazy how long was it up
before they hit you
like six seven hours oh wow that quick
yeah yeah they came to your house or
they called you they called first
and they like asked where i was
and i wasn't home and then i was like
i'll be home at this time i was like i'm
gonna comply like i did nothing wrong
yeah just come on over
yeah